[Música]
en los festivales se acostumbra a cubrir
con flores a quienes han sido elegidos
por los jurados para ellos la grandeza
la gloria y la victoria pero los
derrotados los finalistas que vuelven a
casa sin trofeo deben ser olvidados
[Música]
Pues no ella para la 37 ava edición del
Festival Internacional de la moda 10
finalistas compitieron entre sí tres
fueron premiados vemos la palabra a los
otros siete estas Mentes creativas
adoran la moda en su versión más
combativa
ser comprometida mueve la moda a tener
un mensaje político
en nuestro trabajo hablamos mucho de la
masculinidad de cómo los hombres pueden
expresarse a través de su ropa y eso me
parece muy político
También tenemos un discurso muy fuerte
sobre el medio ambiente y las cuestiones
climáticas
porque la industria de la moda es una de
las más contaminantes del mundo
la industria debe proponer soluciones
para sortear este problema
de modo que podamos respetar los
acuerdos alcanzados en París hace unos
años
es una colección que diseñó Durante los
periodos de reclusión
familiar con un extenso jardín y mi
jardín se convirtió en una especie de
Refugio creativo en ese momento Así que
desarrolle un material a partir de
mangueras de jardín surgió un poco por
casualidad esto es solo una manguera de
jardín no hay ningún material añadido ni
pintura ni nada simplemente corté las
mangueras y las fundí para crear una
especie de piel nueva que casi sustituye
a un cuero u otros materiales para crear
el accesorio principalmente
Cuál es el mensaje de su colección el
mensaje de mi colección es en primer
lugar el deseo de trabajar solo con
materiales en reciclados para mí era muy
importante venir allí para trabajar en
una colección totalmente sostenible
el principal producto que he reciclado
en mi colección son las corbatas
Así que la idea era realmente reunir
diferentes corbatas en el pliegue
creando una nueva pieza a partir de las
antiguas
algunos de sus vestidos son
transformables
Sí por supuesto tengo algunos vestidos
que puedes llevar tanto arriba como
abajo y esto cambiaría la silueta eso es
algo que realmente quería hacer en esta
colección
poder interactuar con la prenda de una
manera diferente
del mismo modelo tienes un vestido con
un aspecto más bien deportivo que puede
transformarse en un vestido de
le he hecho la colección cuenta una
historia la del proceso evolutivo siete
conjuntos diseñados con siete materiales
comienza de forma muy orgánica y termina
con un tejido artificial
le gustan los materiales
claro Me encantan las telas Me encantan
los materiales me encanta la artesanía
realmente se puede ver en toda mi
colección por eso elegí trabajar en
varios materiales y luego intentar
trabajar con un solo material de la
cabeza a los pies
[Música]
lo hizo todo usted mismo
lo hice todo mal haciendo tejido de
crochet y de punto
me llevo mucho tiempo son técnicas que
conducen A la meditación
y también me divertí mucho componiendo
los colores
Cómo añadirlo Solo que estaba Tejiendo o
a lo que hacía ganchillo
es una colección para hombres
exactamente porque me di cuenta mientras
seguía mientras exploraba el tejido que
las líneas entre las nociones de
masculino y femenino se olvidan muy
fluidas
he probado los modelos en mí en mis
amigos otras personas los han llevado
y fue Entonces cuando me di cuenta de
que realmente no importa
si lo quieres lo llevas es un proyecto
muy divertido
en cuanto al séptimo finalista vino
desde Finlandia para llevar su
no quiero ser un niño quiero ser una
princesa Pon nena
Woman
mi moda Es colorida
inteligente y quizás un poco loca
eso es lo que diría pero también me
gusta trabajar con conceptos Twitter
este tipo de identidades
este es el hilo conductor de todo lo que
hago
pero nunca de forma provocativa no nunca
intento provocar a nadie Si alguien se
siente provocado de su culpa no la mía
vivo mi vida intento ser libre y
expresarme A mi manera
esos siete finalistas no habrán ganado
ningún premio pero sus reflexiones sobre
el proceso creativo el trabajo de los
materiales la fluidez de los géneros
demuestran Hasta qué punto el deseo de
transformar la moda está lejos de ser
una